η μεγάλη μά τον ανθρώπο που δεν προκαλούν προβλήματα και και τού το πρά πρ
του πρέα του λέμενη τ το πράμαότι μια μικρημερίδα και και δημουργείνα ένα ζήτημα και
ευτέ συπι ανθρώποι η οποί ποθεν το κανδικαίουμα ότι εστεύουνταιους νόμους για μέαν υ παραπατικό
τα είτε προέχετα ουξένος είτε που κύπρις εν χι θέση νη στην πολύ και ι
αυτό τονλόγο κάναμε εκατός συναντήσεις και σε υπάρχει αεκόν επίπενο και στα κεντρικών επίπεδο καιδρήσαμε
μέτρα ιπροθερα περίπολα μόνιη είνα αστυνομική πάροσιας τις φυνικούες και να φίνούμε στε χρωρών κανή
κανένα προκιμένου να επιληθεί ο το πράμα για τήτα διέτερα προβλήματα τελευταιότιστηνα όμως καταγράφουτα θέρα
πό ότι ότι λάεεπαρτήκαμετρα και μιλούμε για μια νόματα δεκατο δενκάτομ και είπα τους ένα
κράεμπορεί μια παραδέατε εκαδοδα κατώδ κατόμο να προκαλήτου της αναστάσεις βολης έχει υπεύθυνω το κράτος
να να δώ κιλύση και θεωρώ ότι τα τελευταία μέτρα που αρτήκα και κάποια έτς
βήματα θεωρώ ότι εμπροστησο στην κατεύθυση να επιληθεί τουν το θέο αντρέας βίρα τ θέλει
να φχύση στην πόλην του όταν φύγει από την καρέκλαντου δημάρχον να επερπαδουμε στη πολύ
καταρχει ννκλέ μου πάνωυ κιικάτου και ναεγαλεί ο κόσμος τούτος ο άνθρωπος πρόσφερε μέται πράγμασε
πε την πολη ούτε πολλά ούτε μεγάλα το το πράγμα ννό παραπαρπατάδουμε στην ποίκι ανικελές
που πάνω και ο είχαμε σα συχαιρετά ο κόσμος και έναραλί ότι τος ο άνθρωπος
έκανε μέτε πράναθεμεν την πόλη για μεν ναι μεκαλύτρι ανταμιβή και τούτος ζητώ όταν τελειώς
ο που δυμαρχος υπάρχει ένα μαγικό ράδδι για να γίνει λάρνακα ακόμα καλύτερη δηλαδή παλιά
θύμστε τηλεμεσόν υπήρξε μια αύξηση μεγάλη κάποιο την εχρεών να σε διάφορους τομίς λλά υπήρξη
τομαγικό ραυδήν και έγινε ι λεμεσώς πονει ηλάρνακα υπάρχουν υπρόπτκες ώστε α ναπτυχθεί ακόμη περισότεο
θεωρώ ότι μα ηγόρα δενκαρχείν υπάρχει ούτε στη λεμε την πήρχε μαϊκόρας ήταν κάποια στην
κύρία και κάποια έτσι για να ξε καθαρίσω θεωρώ τις στη λάς να καμερής κληρή
δουλειά τον τελευταίο χρόνον ιμόνο που με έτσι να ξε αθαρίσωυν που πάραπολλούς πο δημς